*Titelmusik*
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)
Freunde der Sonne,
herzlich willkommen zu Advent-Chemie.
Heute mit dieser Kerze und
Money, Money, eins nach'm anderen.
Ihr wisst wie das ist, ihr macht es
euch gemütlich, zündet eine Kerze an.
Jetzt habt ihr das Problem,
wie kriegt ihr die Kerze wieder aus?
Ich habe einen Chemie-Livehack,
wie ihr wieder die Kerze auskriegt.
Ihr denkt euch, willst uns erklären,
wie man eine fucking Kerze ausbläst?
Leute, stellt euch vor, ihr habt
morgen einen Tauchwettbewerb
und müsst euren Atem sparen.
Wie kriegt ihr
die Kerze aus ohne zu blasen?
Das geht ganz einfach in 3 Schritten.
Schritt 1: Backpulver.
Schritt Nummer 2: Essig.
Und Schritt Nummer 3:
Einfach das Glas an die Kerze halten.
Magic.
Falls ihr's nicht glaubt,
das Ganze geht auch noch Mal.
Okay, für die Kamera: Kerze,
Backpulver-Essig, wow, magic, magic!
Die Kerze ist aus, aber die Frage
ist, wie kriege ich sie wieder an?
Man könnte jetzt sagen,
mit diesem Feuerzeug.
Aber warum einfach,
wenn es auch geil geht?
Wenn ihr eine Kerze
mit einem Feuerzeug anzünden möchtet,
dabei aber auch Geld verbrennen
möchtet, dann geht das einfach:
in 9 Schritten.
Schritt 1: Wir nehmen eine
1:1-Mischung von Ethanol und Wasser.
Ich hatte zufällig eine 70%-Ethanol-
Lösung zu Hause,
die ich mit destillierten Wasser
auf 1:1 gebracht habe.
Schritt 2:
Wir nehmen einen Geldschein,
klar, je größer der Geldschein,
desto geiler seid ihr.
Ich bin so mittelgeil,
nehme 10 Euro.
Schritt 3: Wir tauchen diesen
Geldschein in den Ethanol-Wasser-Mix.
Ich habe noch etwas vergessen. Eine
Prise Salz und den Schein tränken.
Schritt 4: Ich nehme
meine Desinfektionslösung, 70 %,
und mache einen Tropfen hier drauf.
Besser wäre es,
wenn man 100 % Ethanol nehmen würde.
Hab ich leider nicht da.
Schritt 5:
Wir holen uns eine Schutzbrille.
Wenn ihr eure Brille nicht findet,
könnt ihr auch eure Gesichtsmaske
nehmen, ganz klar.
Schritt 6:
Ihr holt den Geldschein raus.
Schritt 7:
Ihr fasst ihn mit einer Zange an.
Schritt 8: Geldschein anzünden.
Mist.
Freunde der Sonne, ich musste kurz
die Sonne ausschließen,
denn ich habe festgestellt, dass man
die Flamme nicht so gut sieht.
Deswegen Schritt 8
nochmal im abgedunkelten Raum.
Ich mach das mal in diese Kamera,
damit ihr auch schön seht,
wie der Geldschein brennt.
Oh, ja.
Mist.
Nein!
Neeeiiinnn!
Ein Grund mehr für Schritt Nummer 9,
nämlich nicht zu Hause nachmachen.
Freunde der Sonne, ich hoffe
meine Chemie-Livehacks
verändern euer Leben nicht,
zumal ihr sie ja auch nicht
zu Hause ausprobieren sollt.
Aber, wenn ihr wisst, wie die ganze
Magie von heute zu erklären ist,
vom Backpulver über den brennenden
Geldschein bis hin
zu diesem gescheiterten Experiment,
dann schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Denn jede korrekte chemische
Erklärung kriegt von mir persönlich
ein Keks-Emoji.
Bleibt sicher,
wir sehen uns in der Endcard.
(singt)
# I don't want a lot for Christmas
There is just one thing I need
# I don't care about the presents
Underneath the Christmas tree
# I just want you to subscribe
Leave a comment leave a like
# Make my wish come true
All I want for Christmas is you
Baby!